[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday december 9th
i'm kate andrews the spectators
economics editor and your host this week
i think it's worth reflecting before we
dive into the show on this week's press
conference and the introduction of plan
b covid restrictions
there are lots of theories going around
about the timing of these announcements
why more mass mandates
working from home guidance and most
controversially the introduction of
vaccine passports were brought in after
being ruled out by the deputy prime
minister just a day before
we'll dig into those theories on the
show but i want to focus now on the
press conference itself
there's been plenty to challenge in the
countless kobe press conferences we've
had on and off for the better part of
two years patrick valance's infamous
chart last october for example showing
one scenario of cases surging and
nothing else
but wednesday's press conference was
another level of spin
what the prime minister and his advisors
were saying did not translate to what
the graphs on the screen were showing us
the metrics that matter most
hospitalizations and death
have been flatlined for some time now so
in order to claim that the data the
science now required new restrictions
rushed in within a matter of hours they
came up with some disingenuous
comparisons
chris witty tried to draw parallels
between the uk and south africa where he
said hospitalizations were surging
because of the new variant
south africa's double vaccination rate
for the whole population is 25
in the uk it's 70
95 of adults in england and in scotland
are estimated to have antibodies 97
of the over 75s these are not comparable
countries
witty also tried to draw comparisons
between our world now with working
vaccines antivirals and much better
treatment and understanding of cobin 19
and our world last year without these
things
he said of the link between infections
and hospitalizations quote you've seen
how things have gone before that's
probably the way to bet
and then if we're pleasantly surprised
nobody would be happier
than he would be
how can that be said with a straight
face it certainly used to be the case
when we didn't have vaccines that a
soaring infection rate saw
hospitalizations and deaths follow
but when the government opened in july
in cases surged we saw how well that
link between infections and severe
illness had been broken by the vaccines
it's not fully severed it never will be
there are still reasons to be nervous
and the government could have laid out
its plan b strategy on that basis the
unknowns about the omicron variant their
concerns about worst case scenarios
about a health service that is designed
to operate on the brink of catastrophe
still unable to cope with any kind of
unexpected plot twist
but to claim that plan b is based on the
data
the data we have right now
it doesn't add up
and to claim last year's experience
without vaccines should be looked at to
compare to this year's experience with
vaccines and boosters
why are they talking down the jabs
this spin would be a problem at any time
but it matters now especially accepting
the principle of vaccine passports
fundamentally changes the relationship
between the individual and the state
this is a landmark moment and the
government has taken this leap without
any evidence that we need them and
without any evidence that they work
across europe even within the uk we can
look at scotland these passports have so
often failed to make any meaningful
difference
over half of this year has been spent
living under some level of coveted
restrictions we weren't able to sit on a
park bench with another person for three
months this year because we were told to
hang in there the vaccines are the
solution and they are the solution
but
what's the solution now
if they're saying this is no longer the
case what's the exit strategy for
reversing plan b and frankly at some
point ditching the rules that still
existed within plan a
how can we trust they're going to follow
the data when they spin it so
ruthlessly does anyone believe that next
monday when working from home guidance
comes in that ministers in whitehall
will be following it
nothing this week or the entire pandemic
would suggest that rulemakers are
subject to what they mandate for the
rest of us
and on that note on to this week's show
[Music]
you